I love this team here yeah it's like
crime-scene tape and a motel 6 what you
want sure but this show I am so excited
late-night show of all the shows of all
the shows that don't have a host named
Jimmy this is in the format it's it's
conan redacted it's good right you know
I would love to do this show way more
often but you know pride in the way you
look fantastic you Marty thank you you
look like a ginger crash-test dummy look
at this whole decision for your makeup
team to go from makeup to spackle it's
so like mr. Rogers if mr. Rogers drank
before each performance this guy's been
in the business on me he's been around
quite a while you have met them all from
bogey to Bacall you've met every star
and I'm curious so you're always playing
to the kids aren't you
now our Janu your cloud gable
impersonation don't give us anyway
uncanny it's like having Clark bag you
I'm just you know yes
no he lost he passed recently oh don't
touch you again don't touch